on the top of a remote hill by the
village of andara in Northern Syria
about 40 kilometers Northwest of Aleppo
lie the remains of a 3 000 year old
Temple
excavated mostly in the 1980s this
remarkable archaeological site was sadly
damaged in 2018 in the course of the
Syrian Civil War by Turkish air
bombardment destroying over half of the
excavated Temple
but until then it represented one of the
most distinctive sanctuaries in the
region dating to the early Iron Age
the layout of the temple with a
three-part structure consisting of a
columned portico an anti-chamber in the
middle and an inner Hall
aligns closely with the description of
Solomon's Temple in Jerusalem in the
Bible
and probably stems from the same broad
tradition of religious architecture
but the most striking feature of the
andara temple are the footprints
four gigantic Footprints carved into the
Limestone blocks on the floor two at the
Portico entrance a single left footprint
on the Block in front of it and another
right footprint on the threshold between
the anti-chamber and the inner Hall
there's little doubt that what these
represent are the footprints of the
Superhuman sized deity striding into the
sanctuary
the footprints at andara are a powerful
illustration of a fundamental religious
idea in the ancient near East namely
that the temple was the home of the god
the place where the deity resided and
therefore where the divine presence
could be made manifest
in most languages of the ancient near
East temples were simply referred to as
the house of the god with the same word
for house as would be used for any
individual
a temple then at its most basic was just
where the god lived it may also share
characteristics with what we might term
a palace to the extent that the God was
also a king
but the idea of Temple as Divine Abode
was the foundational concept out of
which so many other ideas and practices
were derived from animal sacrifices to
Priestly activities to the internal
architecture of these structures
what happens though when a temple is
destroyed
what do you do when the home of your God
and the place where you perform your
acts of veneration and convene with the
Divine is conquered by an enemy and is
no more
this was no doubt a sad situation that
was encountered with some regularity in
the ancient world and it would be
difficult to generalize regarding a
typical reaction
but in at least one case that we can
identify it seems that the destruction
of a temple prompted at least some
worshipers of that Temple's deity to
completely reimagine this conception of
divine presence
for this group at least the trauma of
Temple destruction and also of Exile
inspired a theological vision of a god
whose Temple was not an isolated
structure on a remote Hilltop or even in
the center of a city like Jerusalem but
consisted of the entirety of the heavens
and the Earth
this was a God for whom all of creation
was his abode
in this lecture we'll examine what is
undoubtedly the best known creation
story from the ancient near East a story
that has transcended its ancient near
Eastern context to become the most
familiar religious conception of
Creation in the popular imagination
this is of course the story of Creation
in seven days in the Bible in Genesis
chapter 1.
but while this is a story with which
many people have at least a passing
familiarity those outside of biblical
scholarship generally don't recognize
the richness of this text in terms of
its structure patterns and layers of
meaning
in particular no complete understanding
of this chapter is possible without some
awareness of the characteristics of
temples in the ancient near East because
as I will endeavor to show the entirety
of Creation in Genesis 1 is presented in
the text as the Temple of the God who is
Creator the story in question as the
first chapter in the book of Genesis
stands at the very beginning of both the
Jewish and Christian Bibles
since the chapter essentially narrates
the beginning of everything what the
text describes as God creating the
heavens and the Earth it serves as a
fitting introduction to the Bible as a
whole
but the Primacy of this story in the
canonical arrangement of the Bible as we
have it now does not actually reflect
the place of this text in the history of
the composition of the Bible that is the
order in which the stories themselves
were written
in fact the conventional scholarly view
is that Genesis chapter 1 is among the
latest biblical texts to be written and
added to the Bible or at least later
than the rest of the Torah or pentateuch
the books of Genesis to Deuteronomy that
form the first section of the Bible
why would a later text be placed first
well this is actually not so hard to
understand
think of the Contemporary practice in
which subsequent editions of a book are
reissued with a new preface or
introduction
for popular books that sell many copies
and go through multiple editions one can
sometimes find multiple prefaces each
one placed at the beginning and before
the prior ones
so for instance a second edition of a
book with a new updated preface we'll
have that preface placed first
because it reframes the original version
of the book recasts it in light of the
new situation
the reception of the book since its
original publication and so forth
this General phenomenon that we might
call revision through introduction to
borrow a phrase from The Scholar Sarah
milstein is a recognized method by which
ancient scribes modified the texts that
they had before them
by adding a new introductory passage to
a previous text one is able to recast
the work as a whole without technically
speaking changing the traditional text
that was received
this was not the only method by which
ancient scribes did their work of
editing but it was a significant one
what is the nature of this introductory
Edition that Genesis 1 represents
within biblical scholarship this seven
day creation story is typically
attributed to a body of tradition known
as the Priestly Source or simply the
letter P for short that is a set of
texts associated with the priests of the
temple in Jerusalem and their
descendants
under the conventional understanding
this Priestly author was also
responsible for compiling the ritual
laws in the Torah primarily The Book of
Leviticus with its instructions on
animal sacrifices but also the
instructions for the Wilderness
Tabernacle in the latter half of the
book of Exodus as well as additional
laws in the Book of Numbers
alongside these laws the Priestly
tradition includes a number of stories
as well as genealogies involving the
characters in the book of Genesis
more importantly all of these texts
share certain features of Outlook style
and vocabulary that are quite
distinctive
in particular an emphasis on concepts of
order and Holiness sets these texts
apart from other texts in the Torah
historically the Priestly Source in the
Torah is to be located during the time
of the Babylonian exile another point
that has significant bearing on how we
read these texts while there's some
debate about this among biblical
Scholars I believe the best explanation
for the nature of the Priestly source as
we have it is that it represents the
codification of literary Traditions
associated with the former Jerusalem
priesthood in the aftermath of the
destruction of the temple itself in 586
BCE
when the city of Jerusalem was conquered
by the Babylonians under King
Nebuchadnezzar II with its Temple
destroyed and its people exiled to
Babylonia the priesthood faced the acute
need to preserve its literary traditions
and its history as well as to rethink
their very identity in a world without a
physical Temple
the Priestly source is the product of
these efforts
this understanding of the historical
context helps to explain the setting of
the sacrificial laws within the
idealized past of the Wilderness
Tabernacle as well as the distinctive
ideology expressed in the texts that
we're focusing on here that the
destruction of the physical Jerusalem
Temple didn't imply the defeat of their
God because the entirety of creation the
heavens and the Earth is God's true
Temple in addition as we'll see there
are quite a number of details in this
text that are reminiscent of ideas found
in Mesopotamian creation accounts and
this would make perfect sense if in fact
the Priestly Source took literary shape
in the context of Exile in Mesopotamia
itself in Babylonia
[Music]